The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: Well, OK,
I am happy to be back,
and I am really happy
about the project
proposals that are coming in.
This is like, OK, this is really
a good part of the course.
And so keep them coming, and
I'm happy to give whatever
feedback I can on
those proposals,
and do make a start there.
They're really good, and
if some are completed
before the end of
the semester and we
can to offer you a
chance to report on them,
that that's good too.
So well done with
those proposals.
So today, I'm
jumping to part six.
So part six and part
seven are optimization
which is the fundamental
algorithm that
goes into deep learning.
So we've got to start
with optimization.
Everybody has to
get that picture,
and then part seven
will be the structure
of CNNs, Convolution
Neural Nets,
and all kinds of applications.
And so can we start
with optimization?
So first, can I like
get the basic facts
about three terms
of a Taylor series?
So that's the typical.
It's seldom that we would
go up to third derivatives
in optimization.
So that's the most useful
approximation to a function.
Everybody recognizes it.
Here, I'm thinking of
F as just one function,
and x as just one
variable, but now
I really want to go
to more variables.
So what do I have
to change if F is
a function of more variables?
So now, I'm thinking of x as--
well, now let me see.
Yeah, I want n variables here.
x is x1 up to xn.
So just to get
the words straight
so we can begin on
optimization, so what
will be the similar step
so the function F at x--
remember, x is n variables.
OK?
Now, what do I have?
Delta x, so what's the
point about delta x now?
It's a vector, delta
x1 to delta xn,
and what about the
derivative of F?
It's a vector too,
the derivative
of F with respect to
x1, the derivative of F
with respect to x2, and so on.
What do I have to
change about that?
I know those guys are vectors,
so it's their dot product.
So it's delta x transpose
at vector times this dF/dx.
So now I'm replacing this
by all the derivatives,
and it's the gradient.
So the gradient of F at
x is the derivatives--
let's see.
It's essential to get the
notation straight here.
Yeah, so it'll be the
partial derivatives
of the function F. So grad F
is the partial derivatives of F
with respect to x1 down to
partial derivative with respect
to xn.
OK, good.
That's the linear term, and
now what's the quadratic term?
1/2, now delta x isn't
a scalar anymore.
It's a vector.
So I'm going to have
delta x transpose
and a delta x, and
what goes in between
is the second
derivatives, but I've
got a function of n variables.
So now, I have a matrix
of second derivatives,
and I'll call it H. This is the
matrix of second derivatives,
Hjk is the second derivative
of F with respect to xj and xk,
and what's the
name for this guy?
The Hessian, Hessian matrix.
How the Hessians got into
this picture I don't know.
The only Hessians
I know are the ones
who fought in the
Revolutionary War for somebody.
Who?
Which side were they on?
I think maybe the wrong side.
The French were
on our side and--
Anyway, Hessian
matrix, and what are
the facts about that matrix?
Well, the first fact is
that it's [INAUDIBLE]
and the key fact
is it's symmetric.
Yeah.
OK, and again, it's
an approximation.
And everybody recognizes
that if n is very large,
and we have a function
of many variables.
Then, we had n derivatives
to compute here,
and about 1/2 n
squared derivatives.
The 1/2 comes from the
symmetry, but the key point
is the n squared derivatives
to compute there.
So computing the
gradient is feasible
if n is small or
moderately large.
Actually, by using
automatic differentiation,
the key idea of
back propagation,
back prop, you can
speed up the computation
of derivatives quite amazingly.
But still for the size
of deep learning problems
that's out of reach.
OK.
So that's the
picture, and then I
will want to use this
to solve equations.
There is a parallel
picture for a vector f.
So now, this is a
vector function.
This is f1 of x up to fn
of x, an x is x1 to xn.
So I have n functions
of n variables,
n functions of n variables.
Well, that's exactly what
I have in the gradient.
Think of these two as
parallel, the parallel
being f corresponds
to the gradient of F,
n functions of n variables.
OK.
Now maybe, what I'm after
here is to solve f equals 0.
So I'm going to think about
the f at x plus delta x,
so it starts with f of x.
And then we have the
correction times the matrix
of first derivatives, and
what's the name for that matrix
of first derivatives?
Well, if I'm just
given n functions--
yeah, what am I after here?
I'm looking for the Jacobian.
So here we'll go the Jacobian,
J. This is the Jacobian named
after Jacoby, Jacobian matrix.
And what are its entries?
J, the jk entry
is the derivative
of the J function with
respect to the kth variable,
and I'm stopping at
first order there.
OK, so these are sort of
like facts of calculus,
facts of 18.02 you could say.
Multivariable calculus,
that's the point.
Notice that we're doing just
like the first half of 18.02,
just do differential calculus,
derivatives, Taylor series.
We're not doing
multiple integrals.
That's not part
of our world here.
OK, so that's the background.
Now, I want to look
at optimization.
So over here, I
want to optimize--
well, over here, let me
try to minimize F of x,
and I'll be in the
vector case here.
And over here, I want
to solve f equals 0,
and of course, that
means f of 1 equals 0
all the way along
to fn equals 0.
Here, I have n equations,
and n unknowns.
Let me start with
that one, and I'll
start with Newton's
method, Newton's method
to solve these n
equations and n unknowns.
OK, so Newton, Newton's
method which is often
not presented in 18.02.
That's a crime, because
that's the big application
of gradients in Jacobians.
OK, so I'm trying to solve
n equations and n unknowns,
and so I want f at x
plus delta x to be 0.
Right?
So I want f of x
plus delta x to be 0.
So f at x plus delta x is--
I'm putting in a 0.
I'm just copying that equation--
is f at where I am.
Let me use K for
the case iteration.
So I'm at a point xK.
I want to get to
a point xK plus 1.
And so I have 0 is f of
x plus J, at that point,
times delta x which
is xK plus 1 minus xK.
Good.
That's Newton's method.
Of course, 0 isn't quite true.
Well, 0 will be true if I'm
constructing xK plus 1 here.
I'm constructing xK plus 1.
OK.
So let me just rewrite that,
and we've got Newton's method.
So we're looking for this
change, xK plus 1 minus xK.
I'll put it on this side
as plus xK, so that's this.
Now, I have to invert
that and put it
on the other side
of the equation.
So that will go with a minus.
This guy will be
inverted and f at xK.
So that's Newton's methods.
It's natural.
So let me just repeat that.
You see where the xK plus
1 minus xK is sitting?
Right?
And I moved f of xK to the
other side with a minus sign,
and then I multiplied through
by J inverse, so I got that.
So that's Newton's method
for a system of equations,
and over there, I'm going to
write down Newton's method
for minimizing a function.
This is such basic stuff
that we have to begin here.
Let me even begin with an
extremely straightforward
example of Newton's method here.
Suppose my function--
suppose I've only
got one function actually.
Suppose I only had one function.
So suppose my function
is x squared minus 9,
and I want to solve
f of x equals 0.
I want to find the
square root of 9.
OK, so what is
Newton's method for it?
My point is just to see how
Newton's method is written
and then rewrite it a little bit
so that we see the convergence.
OK, so of course,
the Jacobian is 2x.
So Newton's method
says that xK plus 1--
I'm just going to copy
that Newton's method--
minus 1 over 2xK.
Right?
That's the derivative times f at
xK which is xK squared minus 9.
OK.
We followed the formula,
this determines xK plus 1,
and let's simplify it.
So here I have xK minus
that looks like 1/2 of xK,
so I think I have
1/2xK, and then
this times this is
9/2 of 1 over xK.
Is that right?
1/2 of xk from this stuff
and plus 9/2 of 1 over xK.
OK.
Can I just like check that
I know the answer is 3?
Can I be sure that I
get the right answer, 3?
That if xK was exactly 3, then
of course, I expect xK plus 1
to stay at 3.
So does that happen?
So 1/2 of 3 and 9/2 of 1/3,
what's that, 1/2 of 3 and 9/2
of 1/3?
OK, that's 3/2 and 3/2.
That's 6/2, and that's 3.
OK.
So we've checked that the method
is consistent which just means
we kept the algebra straight.
But then the really important
point about Newton's method
is to discover how
fast it converges.
So now let me do
xK plus 1 minus 3.
So now, I'm looking at the
error which is, I hope,
approaching 0.
Is it approaching 0?
How quickly is it approaching 0?
These are the fundamental
questions of optimization.
So I'm going to subtract
3 from both sides somehow.
OK, from here, I guess,
I'm going to subtract 3.
So I was just checking
that it was correct.
OK.
Now, so xK plus 1
minus 3, I'm going
to subtract 3 from both sides.
I'm going to subtract 3
there, and then I hope that--
that box is what goes down here.
Right?
Subtracted 3 from both sides, so
I'm hoping now things go to 0.
OK, so what do I have there?
Let me factor out the 1 over xK.
So what do I have then left?
1 over xK, so there's a
9/2 from there, 1 over xK.
So I really have
1/2 of xK squared,
because I've divided by an xK.
And this minus 3, I
better put minus 3xK,
because I'm dividing by xK.
I claim that that's--
now I've got it.
And let's see, let
me take out the 2--
2, forget these 2s,
and make that a 6.
So I have 1 over 2xK times
9 plus xK squared minus 6.
Anything good about that?
We hope so.
We hope that that is
something attractive.
So this is, again, the
error at set K plus 1,
and it's 1 over 2xK times
this thing in brackets--
9 plus xK squared minus 6xK.
And we recognize that
as xK minus 3 squared.
xK squared minus 6 of them plus
9, that's xK minus 3 squared.
OK, that was the
goal, of course.
That's the goal that shows why
Newton's method is fantastic.
If you can execute it, if
you can start near enough,
notice that--
so how do I describe
this great equation?
It says that the error is
squared at every step, squared
at every step.
So if I'm converging to a
limit, it will satisfy the--
it'll be 3, or I guess
minus 3, is that possible?
Yeah, minus 3 is
another solution here.
So we've got two solutions.
Newton's method
could converge to 3.
Am I right, it could
converge to minus 3?
So I'd have a similar equation
sort of centered at minus 3,
or does it always
do one of those?
It could blow up.
So there are sort of
regions of attraction.
They're all the starting
points that approach 3,
and the whole point
of that equation
is with quadratic
convergence the error
being squared at every step.
It zooms in on 3.
Then, there is all
the starting points
that would go to minus
3, and then there
are the starting points
that would blow up.
And those, maybe for
this very simple problem,
the picture is not too
difficult to sort out
those three regions.
And this is allowing for a
vector, two equations or n
equations, then
we're in n variables,
and really you get
beautiful pictures.
You get some of the type
of pictures that gave rise
to these books on fractals,
picture books on fractals
for these basins of attraction.
Does the starting point lead
you to one of the solutions,
or does it lead you to infinity?
Here, that would be interesting
to just draw it for this,
but the essential point is
the quadratic convergence,
if it's close enough.
You see that it has to be close.
If x0 is pretty near 3, then
this is about 1/6 of that,
and there would be a good region
of attraction in this case.
OK.
So that's Newton's
method for equations.
And now I want to
do Newton's method.
I just want to convert
all those words over
to Newton's method
for optimization.
So remember, these boards
were solving f equals 0.
This board is
minimizing capital F,
and what's the
connection between them?
Well of course, this corresponds
to solving the gradient
equals 0.
At a minimum, if
I'm minimizing, I'm
finding a point where all
the first derivatives are 0.
So that will be the
match between these.
This grad F in this picture is
the small f in that picture.
OK.
Now, I guess here I have--
and this is sort of the
heart of our applications
to deep learning-- we have
very complicated loss functions
to minimize,
functions of thousands
or hundreds of
thousands of variables.
OK.
So that means that we would
like to use Newton's method,
but often we can't.
So I need him to put
down here two methods--
one that doesn't involve
those high second derivatives
and Newton's that does.
So first, I'll write down a
method that does not involve,
so method one, and this
will be steepest descent.
And what is that?
That says that xK plus 1--
the new x is the old x minus--
steepest descent means that I
move in the steepest direction
which is the direction
of the gradient of F.
I move some distance,
and I better
have freedom to decide what
that distance should be.
So this is a step size, s, or in
the language of deep learning,
it's often called
the learning rate,
so if you see learning rate.
OK.
So and it's natural
to choose sK.
We're going along, do you see
what this right-hand side looks
like?
I'm at a point in n dimensions.
We're in n dimensions here.
We have functions
of n variables.
There is a vector.
There is a direction to
move down the steepest slope
of the graph.
And here is a distance to
move, and we will stop.
We'll have to get off
this step, normally.
If we stay on it,
it will swing back,
it'll take us off to infinity.
You would like to choose
sK so that you minimize
capital F. You take the point on
this line, so this a line in R
n, a direction in R n.
And for all the points on
that line, in that direction,
F has some value, and what
you expect is that initially,
because you chose it sensibly,
the value of F will drop.
But then at a certain point,
it will turn back on you
and increase.
So that would be the
natural stopping point.
I would call that an
exact line search.
So I exact line search would be,
exact line search is the best
s.
Of course, that would
take time to compute,
and you probably,
in deep learning,
that's time you can't afford,
so you fix the learning rate s.
Maybe you choose 0.01
to be pretty safe.
OK, so that's method
one, steepest descent.
Now, method two will
be Newton's method.
So now, we have xK plus 1
equal to xK minus something
times delta F, and now I'm
going to do the right thing.
I'm going to live right
here, and the right thing
is the Hessian, the
second derivative.
This was cheap.
We just took the direction
and went along it.
Now, we're getting really
the right direction
by using the second derivative,
so that's H inverse.
OK, and what I've
done is to set that 0.
Do you see that's
Newton's method?
It's totally
parallel to this guy.
Actually, I'm really happy to
have these two on the board
parallel to each other, because
you have to keep straight,
are you solving equations, or
are you minimizing functions?
And you're using different
letters in the two problems,
but now you see how they match.
The Jacobian of-- so
again the matches,
think of f as the
gradient of F. That's
the way you should think of it.
So the Jacobian of the
gradient is the Hessian.
The Jacobian of the
gradient is the Hessian,
and that makes sense,
because the first derivative
of the first derivative
is the second derivative.
Only we're doing matrix y, so
the Jacobian of the gradient--
we're doing a vector
matrix sentence
instead of a scalar sentence--
the Jacobian of the gradient
is a Hessian.
Yeah, right.
OK, so that's what I
wanted to start with,
just to get those
basic facts down.
And so the basic facts were
the three-term Taylor series.
And then the basic algorithms
followed naturally from it
by setting f F at
the new point to 0,
if that's what you were
solving or by assuming
you had the minimum.
Right, good, good, good, good.
OK.
Now, what?
Now, we have to think about
solving these problems,
studying.
Do they converge?
What rate do they converge?
Well, the rate of
convergence is like why
I separated off this example.
So the convergence rate
for Newton's method
will be quadratic.
The error gets squared,
and of course, that
means super-fast convergence,
if you start and close enough.
The rate of convergence
for a steepest descent
is, of course, not.
You're not squaring errors
here, because you're just
taking some number
instead of the inverse
of the correct matrix, so
you can't expect super speed.
So a linear rate of
convergence would be right.
You would like to
know that the error is
multiplied at every step
by some constant below 1.
That would be a
linear rate compared
to being squared at every step.
OK, and so this will
be our basic formula
that we build on for really
large scale problems.
And there are
methods, of course,
people are going to come up
with methods that they're sort
of a cheap Newton's method.
Levenberg-Marquardt,
and it's in the notes
at the end of this
section, at the end of 6.4
that we'll get to.
So Levenberg-Marquardt is a sort
of cheap man's Newton's method.
It does not compute to
Hessian, but it says, OK,
from the gradient, I can
see one term in the Hessian.
So it grabs that term, but
it's not fully second order.
OK.
So now, we have to
think about problems,
and I guess the message here
is, at our starting point,
has to be convexity.
Convexity is the key
word for these problems,
for the function that
we want to minimize.
If that's a convex
function, well first of all,
the convex function is
likely to have one minimum.
And the picture that's in
our mind of steepest descent,
this picture of a bowl,
a bowl is the graph
of the convex function.
So I'm turning to convexity now.
I'll leave that board there,
because that's pretty crucial,
and speak about the
idea of convexity.
Convex function, convex
set, so let's call
the function f of x,
and a typical convex set
would be I'll call it K. OK.
So we just want to remember what
does that word can convex mean,
and how do you know if
you have a convex function
or a convex set?
OK, let me start
with convex set.
So because here is
my general problem,
my convex minimization,
which you hope to have,
and in many applications,
you do have.
So you minimize
a convex function
for points in a convex set.
So that's like the
ideal situation.
That's the ideal
situation, to get something
on your side, something
powerful, convexity.
The function is convex,
and you say, well,
let me draw a convex
function, the graph.
OK, so I'll draw a convex
function, say a bowl.
So that's a graph of f of x,
and then here are the x's.
Let me maybe put x1 and x2 in
the base and the graph of f
of 1x x2 up here.
OK.
Actually, I'm over there.
I should be calling this
function F, I think.
Is that right?
Yeah, a little f would be
the gradient of this guy.
Yeah, I think so.
OK.
Now, I'm minimizing it over
certain x's, not all x's.
I might be minimizing,
for example,
K might be the set where
Ax equals B. K might be,
in that case, a subspace
or a shifted subspace.
I said subspace, but then 18.06
is reminding me in my mind
that I only have a
subspace when B is 0.
You know the word for a subspace
that's sort of moved over?
Affine, so I'll just
put that word down here.
Bunch of words to
learn for this topic,
but they're worth learning.
OK.
So it's like a plane but not
necessarily through the origin.
If B is 0, it doesn't
go through it.
If B it's not 0, it doesn't
go through the origin.
OK.
Anyway, or I have
some other convex set.
Let me just put this convex
set K in the base for you,
and did I make it convex?
I think pretty luckily I did.
So now what's the?
Well, the convex
sets the constraint,
so this is the constraint set.
Constraint is that x
must be in the set K. OK,
and I drew it as a convex blob.
Here was an example
where it's flat, not
a blob but a flat plane.
But let me come back to
what does convex mean.
What's a convex set?
Yeah, we have to do that,
should have done that before.
In the notes, I had the
fun of figuring out,
if I took a triangle,
is that a convex set?
Let's just be sure.
So what's a convex set?
That is a convex
set, because if I
take any two points in the set
and draw the line between them,
it stays in the set.
So that's convexity,
any edge, line, from x1
to x2 stays in the set.
OK, good.
So here's my little
exercise to myself.
What if I took the
union of two triangles?
All I want to get you to do is
just visualize convex and not
convex possibilities.
Suppose I have one triangle,
even if it was obtuse,
that's still convex, right?
No problem.
But now what if I put
those two triangles
together, take their union?
Well, if I take them sitting
with a big gap between,
like I've lost.
I mean, I never had
a chance that way,
because if it was the
union of these two-- well,
you know what I'm going to say.
If I'm doing that point
and that point, of course,
it goes outside and stupid.
All right.
What if what if that
triangle, that lower triangle,
overlaps the upper triangle?
Is that a convex set?
Everybody's right saying no.
Why how do I see that the
union of those two triangles
is not a convex set?
Guys, you tell me where
to pick two points,
where the line goes out.
Well, I take one from
that corner and one
from that corner, and the line
between them went outside.
So union is usually not convex.
Well, if I think of
the union of two sets,
my mind automatically goes
to the other corresponding
possibility which is the
intersection of the two sets.
So if I take the
intersection of two sets.
Now, what's the deal with that?
When I had two triangles,
two separated triangles,
what can we say about the
intersection of those two
triangles?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: It's empty.
So should we regard the
empty set as a convex set?
Yes.
Isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's vacuous.
GILBERT STRANG: Vacuous, so
it hasn't got any problems.
Right?
OK, but now the intersection
is always convex.
I'm assuming the two sets
that we start with are.
Now, that's an important fact,
that the intersection of convex
sets.
Let's just draw a picture
that shows an example.
So what's the intersection?
Just this part and it's convex.
OK, can you give
me a little proof
that the intersection is convex?
So I take two points
in the intersection--
let me start the proof.
To test if something's
convex, how do you test it?
You take two points in the
set in the intersection,
and you want to show that
the line between them
is in the intersection.
OK, why is that?
So take two points, take
x1 in the intersection.
We've got two sets
here, and that's
the symbol for
intersection, and we've
got another point
in the intersection.
And now, we want to look
at the line between them,
the line from x1 to 2x.
What's the deal with that one?
Is that fully in K1?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GILBERT STRANG: Why
is it fully in K1?
I took two points
in the intersection,
I'm looking at the line
between them, and I'm asking,
is it in the first set K1?
And the answer is yes,
because those points
were in K1, and K1's convex.
And is that line
between them in K2?
Yes, same reason, the
two endpoints were in K2,
so the line between
them is in K2.
So the intersection of
convex sets is always convex.
The intersection of
convex sets is convex.
Good.
So you'll see in the
note these possibilities
with two triangles.
Sometimes, you can take the
union but not very often.
OK.
Now, what's the next
thing I have to do?
Convex functions,
we got convex sets,
what are convex
functions, and we're good.
Because this is our
prototype of a problem,
and I now want to know what
it means for that F to be--
oh, I'm sorry.
I now know what it means for
the set K to be convex set,
but now I have to look at the
other often more important part
of the problem.
What's the function
I'm minimizing,
and I'm looking for functions
with this kind of a picture.
OK.
The coolest way is to connect
the definition of a convex
function to the definition
of a convex set.
This is really the nicest way.
It's a little quick.
It just swishes by you.
But tell me, do you see a
convex set in that picture?
[INAUDIBLE]
You see a convex
set in that picture.
That's the picture of a
graph of a convex function.
It's a picture of a bowl.
Are the points on that
surface, is that a convex set?
No, certainly not.
No, but where is a convex set to
be found here, in that picture?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The set of y, if y
is greater than [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: Yes, the
points on and above the bowl,
inside the bowl, we
could say, these points.
So convex function,
yes, a function's
convex when the points on and
above the graph are convex set.
You could say,
OK, mathematicians
are just being lazy.
Having got one definition
straight for a convex set,
now they're just using that
to give an easy definition
of a convex function.
Actually, it's quite
useful for functions
that could maybe equal infinity,
sort of generalized functions.
But it's not the quickest way to
tell if the function is convex.
It's not our usual test
for convex functions.
So now I want to
give such a test.
OK.
So now, the definition of convex
function, of a smooth convex,
yeah.
This fact, I shouldn't
rush off away from it,
from the definition
of a convex function
as having a convex
set above its graph.
The really official French name
for the set above the graph
is the epigraph, but I won't
even write that word down.
OK.
Why do I come back
to that for a minute?
Because I would like to think
about two functions, F1 and F2.
Out of two functions,
I can always
create the minimum
or the maximum.
So suppose I have to convex
functions, convex function
F1 and F2.
OK.
Then, I could choose a minimum.
I could choose my new function.
Shall I call it
little m for minimum?
m of x is the
minimum of F1 and F2.
And I could choose
a maximum function
which would be the
maximum of F1 of x and F2
of x at the same point x.
It's just a natural to think,
OK, I have two functions.
I've got a bowl and
I've got another bowl,
and suppose they're both convex.
So I'm just stretching
you to think here.
If I've got the graphs
of two convex functions,
and I would like to consider the
minimum of those two functions
and also the maximum
of those two functions.
I believe life is good.
One of these will be
convex, and the other won't.
And can you identify
which one is convex
and which one is not convex?
What about the minimum?
Is that a convex function?
So just look at the graph.
What does the minimum look like?
The minimum is this guy
until they meet somehow
on some surface
and then this guy.
Is that convex?
We have like one minute
to answer that question.
Absolutely no.
It's got this bad kink in it.
What about the maximum
of the two functions?
So the maximum is the
one that is above,
all the points or things
that are above or on.
There is the maximum function.
That was the minimum function.
It had a kink.
The maximum function
is like that,
and it is convex, so
maximum yes, minimum no.
OK, and we could have a
maximum of 1,500 functions.
If the 1,500 functions
are all convex,
the maximum will
be, because it's
the part way above
everybody's graph,
and that would be the
graph of the maximum.
OK, good.
And now finally, let me
just say, how do you know
whether a function is convex?
How to test, how of test.
OK, so let me take just a
function of one variable.
What's the test you learned
in calculus, freshman
calculus actually, just show
that this is a convex function?
What's the test for that?
AUDIENCE: Use second derivative.
GILBERT STRANG: Second
derivative should be?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
GILBERT STRANG:
Positive or possibly 0,
so second derivative greater
or equals 0 everywhere.
That's convex.
OK, final question,
suppose F is a vector.
So this is a vector, and so I
have n functions of n variable.
No, I don't.
I have one, sorry,
I've got one function,
but I'm in n variables.
So this was just one.
What's the test for convexity?
So it would be passed, for
example, by x1 squared plus x2
squared.
Would it be passed by--
so here would be the
question-- would it
be passed by x transpose
some symmetric matrix S?
That would be a quadratic,
a pure quadratic.
Would it be convex?
What would be the test?
I'm looking for an n
dimensional equivalent
of positive second derivative.
The n dimensional equivalent
of positive second derivative
is convexity, and we have to
recognize what's the test.
So I could apply it
to this function,
or I could apply it to any
function of n variables.
It should be OK.
What's the test here?
Here, I have a matrix
instead of a number.
So what's the
requirement going to be?
Times out, yeah?
[INAUDIBLE] Positive
definite or semidefinite,
or semidefinite just as here.
Yeah.
So the test is positive,
semidefinite, Hessian.
And here, the Hessian
is actually that S,
because the second
derivatives will produce--
I'll put a 1/2 in there--
the second derivatives will
produce S equal the Hessian H.
So here, the S--
so positive
semidefinite, Hessian
in general, second derivative
matrix for a quadratic.
OK.
So its convex
problems that we're
going to get farther with.
We run into no saddle points.
We run into no local minimum.
Once we found the minimum,
it's the global minimum.
These are the good problems.
OK, again, happy
to see you today,
and I look forward to Wednesday.